what has joel mchale
done now i feel like you're accusing me
of murder
you're saying something like what have
you done
hi everybody it's me joel mchale today
i'll be doing the wired auto complete
interview
here we go guys why
joel mchale why joel mchale
tiger king why not well that fell into
my lap because
ted sarandos basically was just like do
you want to host the follow-up special
to tiger king
and kovid it was just as thi it was like
a week after it was
all locked down you know it was when you
thought well if i look at someone weird
they're going to get coveted or maybe
i'm going to get covered if i look at
them too long i don't know so i
got to host that thing and it's i know
it's a part of the actual series but i
had nothing to do with it i
barely i showed up and recorded some
things i did talk to those people for
a very long time so even though that
special is like
33 minutes long or something i talked to
each of them for like two hours
it was it was exhausting i don't know
how i'd do it i don't know
we almost got joe exotic but the prison
or the
the jail he was in uh got a covet scare
so that went away very quickly why is
joel mchale
famous that is a good question
why is joel mchale podcast
why why do we do a podcast uh ken is one
of my good good
good friends if not one of my great
friends you know i'm joke but he's a
real doctor i mean he really knows what
he's doing and i would call him and ask
him about the
virus and he we kind of like hey we
should do a podcast and talk about this
and then
we'll talk to our friends after that and
so that's how
that started and ken knows what he's
talking about
i just read articles and then pretend to
know what i'm talking about
uh some publicist called me and be like
um we would like to put our client on
your podcast can you please give us the
name of your booker and i'm like you're
talking to him and
uh and or can we're the bookers so ken's
been
you know on the most successful shows on
tv right now with the mask singer and i
can see your voice and
all the other ones uh and uh so now i
think he that has kind of like he's
he's he's uh he's got a little more free
time
how joel mchale here we go
how tall joel mchale
well i think everybody knows i'm eight
foot one but that's just
the lower half it's very long i am six
four
how old is joel mchale i am 48 years old
so i could be your dad in a lot of cases
your granddad so yeah so
you know let's see some respect 48 yeah
not for much longer next week
no two weeks i'm 49. i'm 49. uh
how does joel mchale
stay in shape thanks for saying that
that's right
i'm doing an ab workout right now so i
do like
40 minutes a day uh sometimes if i've
got a little more free time i'll do an
hour
but i try to carve out and everyone's
like did you take days off i'm like i do
not i try to get it in every day somehow
i want to eat spaghetti carbonara for
every meal
but if you operate at a caloric deficit
you'll
not even stay in shape you'll look like
you're in shape thank you
how much does
joel mchale make for
card sharks how much money do i make for
card sharks
oh well yeah well that's how i might get
paid i have to play the game
myself so some weeks i'm making like
oh for them half a million dollars other
weeks gift certificate
so but i just have to go out there and
turn the cards over myself and then
and the producers always you know like
come on dude keep going you're
you you gotta you got a four up there
it's gotta be higher and then like oh
we're so sorry
we're so sorry we're so sorry
and now a kombucha break
kidding this is chilled red wine
does joel mchale here we go
does joel mchale leave community
no i mean i did i stayed with it all six
years
other people left um but i i certainly
didn't wait did i
and it's still going is that what
happened this show still on
does joel mchale have lions
yes um um because i was paid in
big cats for the tiger king special does
joel mchale
have a brother no i don't i have two
brothers
and people like oh um are you the oldest
and i'm like no
the youngest no i'm i'm like i'm the
middle then they'll go like
totally that's why you became an actor
right because you
you just needed the attention it doesn't
mean you're the middle
what are you talking about yes because
if i had been the youngest one i would
have to have been a pilot
their names are chris and steven we look
alike okay uh does
joel mchale play
accordion it's not play the accordion
it's play accordion i do not play the
accordion i don't play any instrument
bang joel these are all blanks this is
joel mchale
and then just blanks joel mchale
the soup oh takes you back doesn't it
yeah that was the thing that helped me
get the audition for you know like a
zillion like i
um i did not expect that i was gonna be
a host at all
in my career i think everyone thought i
was the next you know
joel edgerton no um i stumbled into that
job and got very lucky because a couple
of couple executives at e decided to
take a shot and
it we boy that's 2005.
geez i didn't have a child then oh no
just no you didn't even have a child
then
yeah those were the days i got to do
that for 12 years it was really fun
joel mchale drag race
wow yes i loved being a judge i think
michelle wanted to rip my head off
michelle and i are friends okay we had a
very fun time that show's amazing
and the amount of work the performers
put in
is staggering and like the changes they
have to make
it is remarkable joel mchale
joel and kale dog no three
three dogs i got a french bulldog a pug
and a thing called a catone dutelier
the french bulldog is a maniac and an
alpha male apex predator
and then our pug i got him on the great
indoors
which was a short-lived show there was a
scene that required
this guest star to be holding a baby pug
the person in charge let me attack that
dog and that dog is here now
and he's the sweetest boy and in the
show the dog's name
was jonathan and the dog the puppy's
name was cowboy
so i brought him home and at that point
my kids were like 11 and 8.
and i was like well the dog's name is uh
cowboy
and um the name of the dog on tv was
jonathan and but i was like you can name
the dog whatever you want and they
looked at me like i was crazy they were
like
the dog's name is cowboy jonathan and i
went okay
it is joel mchale knife collection
correction knife comma sword and weapon
collection
yeah i don't know what's wrong with me
it's just i've always collected knives
and like
nunchucks and billy clubs and throwing
knives
i don't know why and it's weird people
like it's weird i'm like
yeah i just was always obsessed with
them
and i have like it's hard for me not to
go into a knife store if i'm walking by
one
i blog like on instagram i follow a
bunch of knife companies you know to
keep up
and my wife is like can you just put all
those away and i was like yeah and then
i never do
last one on this page zodiac sign
scorpios
which means we have tails that are
poisonous
is joel
is joel mchale oh here we go
nice [ __ ] yeah uh
what are you looking at is joel mchale
related to ryan seacrest his pile of
money goes all the way
to the clouds so he's very nice
successful man
we are not related we worked at e
forever or as i like to call it the
network so i would see him in the
hallways and i would just uh he would
just
he was always so busy counting his money
that so i didn't you know i don't want
to interrupt that
um very nice guy and now he has a beard
copied me
is joel mchale
left-handed oh
why would you ask it's weird i'm
left-handed
for writing and like brushing my teeth
and fine motor skills and i am
right-handed for gross motor skills so
throwing balls and
golfing and batting i could become a
professional athlete if
all my talent was in one arm but alas
it's not we all have crosses to bear and
i would bear mine on my right shoulder
is joel mchale
a lawyer um no
not even close i'm super dyslexic and
cheated my way through high school and
college and everything
i played one and it made it i said words
out loud that sounded like i was one
kind of but um
no i would be a terrible lawyer where
joel mchale okay where is joel mchale
from
seattle is my hometown so uh that's
that's where i'm from and as everybody
know i started a little coffee company
called starbucks a little computer
company called microsoft and some
i helped start an online shopping thing
called amazon
i can't remember the name of it anyway
where did joel mchale
go to college oh thank you i went to the
university of washington
go huskies where has joel mchale
been where have i been where have you
been
i feel like i'm constantly doing
interviews like this so you don't have
to ask that question
where have you been i've been trying to
get your attention this whole time where
have i been
on car sharks on abc sunday nights at 10
o'clock
9 central last one pressure here we go
where did joel mchale meet his wife
oh that's a good question well i met her
twice first time i was a freshman
and she was a senior oh older woman
she's only one year older because i
entered college as an older person
and she was very young for college and i
met her
and i was like that's a very pretty
woman and then i did not see her again
for like three years and then um i was
shooting a movie
a crazy movie in seattle and her mom
was an extra and her brother was a
production assistant
and he reintroduced us and she was like
yeah i know he is i don't need to see
him again and that's when she fell in
love with me no
uh i called my friend kim and i was like
hey do you think you could put a
good word in for me with sarah williams
and she was like
good luck but sarah took pity on me and
um allowed me to
take her out and uh and then i i wore
her down and she then eventually agreed
to marry me
thank god that was almost 24 years ago
and she's regretted it ever since
well that was very fun um thanks for
having me and this is the part of the
show where people would say thank you
wired and then they'd throw the board
but i'm not gonna do that
i'm gonna throw those little things i'll
see you later
i'm off camera right
oh [ __ ]